so the state of flow also known as being
in the zone is a mental state
characterized by complete immersion and
focus in an activity when in a state of
flow an individual is fully engaged and
feels a sense of effortless control and
enjoyment in the task at hand time seems
to pass quickly and distractions are
minimized allowing the individual to
achieve Optimal Performance so hi I'm
schlotzrasa a third year PhD student in
computational neuroscience and during my
master I actually did my research a
little bit on flow or the concept of
flow so we really wanted to see the
underlying neural correlates of the
state called flow and although we didn't
really find anything I do have to say
ever since this time I became really
interested in the idea of flow and how
to reach this feeling of flow in your
daily life so the concept of flow also
known as The Zone was first identified
by a psychologist named mihali and he
created this book called flow the
psychology of optimal experience he
describes flow as a state in which
individuals are completely absorbed in
an activity with a clear goal and
immediate feedback and a balance between
Challenge and skill level and I think
this is really the most important that
you have this balance between your
challenge or what you want to achieve
and the skill that you have so for
example if your skill is a little bit
too low and the challenge is too high
you may become frustrated whereas if
your skill is too high and the challenge
is too low then you may become bored so
you really want to think of this optimal
experience where you feel kind of
challenged and interested but it's not
too difficult for you to achieve so
today I want to talk about the
experience of flow through coding so I
think a lot of coders are really good
programmers experience flow quite often
so they really feel as if time is
passing by without any required effort
for them and they're really in the zone
and they just are programming on music
so this is also something that you've
seen in movies maybe quite a lot and
also something that I've experienced
quite a lot when I'm programming myself
and today I kind of want to give you
some tricks or some tools to get this
experience of flow during your
programming game or if you're interested
in any other type of skill also these
tips will transfer to those skills as
well so let's get straight into it so
the first tip is to pick a time where
you know you have concentration so for
most people the early morning hours are
often the best time for concentration
and cognitive functions the brain is
generally more alert and focused after a
good night of sleep and cortisol levels
which impact focus and alertness are
naturally the highest in the morning so
I usually block out in the morning an
hour of one two three to really focus on
coding and by having this set time every
day you can optimize the chances of you
experiencing flow so as I talked about
before the idea of flow really assumes
that the challenge is high enough for
your skill level so you really have to
think about a project or some kind of
task that you could accomplish that's a
little bit difficult or a little bit
tricky but not too tricky so one thing
that I really like to do is the 100 days
of programming python course so they
increase the difficulty level every day
by just a little bit and I really
noticed that for me this type of
learning to program really worked just
because every day followed up on the
next day and was a little bit more
difficult but I knew I could achieve it
within my skill level then the third tip
is to really eliminate all distractions
I think this is really important if
you've ever been in flow you know that
if someone knocks at your door or if
your phone thinks that you're
immediately out of this zone so
something that you want to do is to
eliminate all these distractions
beforehand so turn off your phone tell
your roommate you're gonna be working
really hard on this important
programming task and you also have these
apps for example for on your laptop that
limit the amount of pings or messages
that you can get on for example your
laptop so I would download all of those
if you know you're prone to distraction
then the fourth tip that I want to give
which I think is probably the most
important is to have the right mindset
so I think the mindset of I want to we
would learn this or I want to really
achieve this it's in my opinion a little
bit wrong because a lot of programming
tasks as you will notice are a little
bit more a creative pursuit or kind of
like a puzzle solving game so I think to
have a curious mindset is actually a lot
more important so one of the things that
I also think is to have this curious
mindset but also a growth mindset so
you've probably heard of this concept
before but the mindset for coding that
is probably the best is the growth
mindset where you approach challenges
and difficulties with a willingness to
learn and grow rather than with a fixed
mindset mindset that see skills as
inherent and unchangeable so if you are
of the mindset like I could never learn
this skill or I could never do this I
think you're already Doom talking
yourself into not achieving what you
want but if you try to reframe The
Narrative by saying like if I just work
on this every day for an hour I will in
the end reach my goals this is kind of
the idea of the growth mindset and could
help you tremendously so these were my
tips for reaching flow in programming if
you have any tips or if you have
experienced this slow State I would love
to know how your feeling of flow was
because I always like to see how other
people experience this date and also if
you think you have some kind of tool or
trick to really get into this state I
would also be really curious to hear
that so put it down in the comments
below and otherwise see you next week
bye